mein name ist sabine platz und für
diesen film rein sich einmal quer durch
deutschland von berlin nach nordrhein
westfalen
ich will wissen wie geht es den menschen
nach mehreren monaten corona krise ist
alles wieder gut alles wieder normal
[Musik]
erinnern sie sich zu beginn der krise
war die spargelernte ein riesenthema die
arbeitskräfte aus dem ausland konnten
nicht einreisen und die landwirte
fürchteten um ihre einnahmen
hallöchen alte fuchs ist geschäftsführer
diese spargelhofs im brandenburgischen
kremmen
noch heute kann er kaum glauben wie
viele menschen ihm damals hilfe anboten
dass ich schon vor deutet anmelden und
wirklich ernsthaft uns hier zur seite
stehen wollten haben wir schon mal
zwischen zeigen die gänsehaut und
feuchte augen gekriegt einer der damals
seine hilfe anbot ist johannes jopi
eigentlich ist der taxifahrer aber als
es kaum noch fahrten gab starke eben
sparen
erst ein paar tage ist man schon so
rumgelaufen wie der schiefe turm von
pisa an
aber dann hat es wirklich spaß gemacht
also insbesondere weil die stimmung in
der truppe wirklich ganz hervorragend
dass der gesamte spargel geerntet werden
konnte für meinte vogts ist das noch
immer ein wunder denn das war ja auch
eine bunte truppe taxifahrer kellner
köche opernsängerin die haben ja nicht
die hand fertigkeiten des fahrgestells
zumindest haben sie nicht die erfahrung
ich bin ganz begeistert wenn ich das
hier noch mal so sehr wie es anfängt die
haben uns alle bis zum ende die treue
gehalten waren homogener guter gute
mannschaft tolle geschichte oder weiter
geht's nach bad sagen wenn man dem
freund hier nicht vorbei kommt dann
dauert es eine weile über im altenheim
in bad saarow angekommen sind
aber irgendwann kommt man immer ins ziel
[Musik]
anke eingeleitet eine private
pflegeeinrichtung seit wenigen tagen
dürfen besucher das gebäude wieder
betreten und auch die tagespflege hat
unter hohen auflagen wieder optisch
ordnung gearbeitet haben dass also der
abstand gewahrt werden kann
das kriegen wir hier alles gut geregelt
und wochenlang konnte diese gruppe nicht
gemeinsam singen und nun sind alle froh
wieder da zu sein
es hat mir noch gefehlt die zweite die
hände woche hier gehen 170 mitarbeiter
hat anke reinker und zu beginn der krise
dem zdf schon einmal ein interview
gegeben und was mich wirklich richtig
freut ist dass also jetzt sich gerade
zeigt dass alle gemeinsam an diesem
einen strang ziehen und einfach nur die
versorgung aller uns anvertrauten
patienten sicherstellen möchten
die chefin hat sich auf alle mitarbeiter
verlassen können und hofft jetzt dass
die anerkennung des pflegeberufs
dauerhaft in der gesellschaft angekommen
ist also die pflege wird immer gebraucht
und ich wünsche mir einfach dass das in
das bewusstsein der menschen gerückt und
vereinigen sich irgendwann auch in der
vergütung dieser arbeit widerspiegelt
und da ist dann letztendlich wieder
politik gefragt normalität kehrt zurück
in bad saarow
aber hier in dieser templiner
westernstadt ist noch alles tot
[Musik]
hallo
das el dorado darf als ich es besucher
noch nicht öffnen
eigentlich aber wäre jetzt hochsaison
bei diesem schönen wetter ist es
natürlich so dass jeder tag richtig weh
tut und man immer schaut was wird nur
aus diesem jahr in normalen zeiten
kommen hunderte besucher täglich
jetzt aber gibt es keine pferde keine
cowboys und indianer und der saloon ist
genauso leer wie alles an
dabei ist doch alles vorbereitet für die
gäste die tische haben den nötigen
abstand und das freilufttheater wartet
auf publikum die stunt shows aber sind
ein problem für die west land statt in
der westernstadt lebt die stuntshow von
der klassischen schlägerei solange sich
unsere stand leute nicht ordentlich
hauen können ist es natürlich schwierig
also wenn schon fressen dann aber
richtig genau
mit beginn der brandenburger
sommerferien sollen die colts hier
wieder rauchen und die kutschen durch
die gassen rasen erst dann ist das
eldorado keine geisterstadt mehr
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen geht meine fahrt in
richtung westen durch sachsen anhalt
das schöne an sachsen anhalt ist das
hier gar nichts los ist kann man einfach
fahren
die zahl der korona infizierten ist
bislang in diesem bundesland sehr
niedrig vom lock down war die
bevölkerung natürlich trotzdem betroffen
hallo jan walsleben hat seinen kaffee in
magdeburg zwar wieder auf aber fast
wöchentlich wechseln die auflagen zu
erfüllen hat die situation ist
beschissen dieser stetige wandel der
politik und der verordnung dem
nachzukommen ist gar nicht mehr so
einfach und das abzuschätzen wird ein
weg den man einschlägt morgen noch
aktuell möglich sein
das sind sehr viele unsicherheiten die
als unternehmer ist sehr schwer machen
entscheidungen zu treffen und die auch
durchzuziehen
weiter geht's nach norden nach bremen
mit dem auf und ab der politik hat auf
das jump haus zu kämpfen die trampolin
kette betreibt sieben sprung hallen in
sechs bundesländern
die hallen sind wieder offen aber
landesweit gelten für freizeitparks
unterschiedliche abstandsregeln in
bremen ein meter fünfzig abstand in
hamburg zwei meter fünfzig und in berlin
drei meter genau so ist es ist enorm
komplex und es ist auch fraglich macht
es nicht sinn einmal eine grundregel
vorzugeben und die dann einfach lokal zu
umzusetzen
till waltz hat im april dem zdf ein
interview gegeben
er fühlte sich damals von der politik im
stich gelassen nur in einem bundesland
hat der hilfe bekommen
in zwei weiteren sind soforthilfen für
uns als mittelständler gar nicht
relevant das heißt wir sind nicht
förderungswürdig nicht förderungswürdig
haben sie hier gesagt wie fühlt sich das
heute ein paar wochen später leider nach
wie vor ähnlich wir sind unternehmerisch
voll in der verantwortung
nur wir können umsatzeinbrüche von 90
prozent nicht kompensieren egal was wir
tun
wir nehmen kredite auf wir verschulden
uns bis unter die dachpappe nur das
absehbar dass wir dieses kreditvolumen
dieses massive schulden volumen nicht
werden auf absehbare zeit wieder
erwirtschaften können an einem normalen
tag springen und toben hier bis zu 800
menschen und wie viele glauben sie
kommen heute nachmittag ist werden die
viele seinem vielleicht 40 50 mit luca
glück so scheint mir kann die gesamte
freizeit industrie in diesen zeiten gut
gebrauchen und touristen davon gibt es
hier am hamburger hafen nämlich noch
immer viel zu wenige wollen auch mein
reich 9
hubert neuper ist praxen unternehmer und
nimmt uns eine runde mit außer seien
aber kassel sich nur wenige schiffe
unterwegs
normalerweise werden hier party schiffe
um uns herum es wäre hier musik hier
würde bier getrunken die leute wären
fröhlich das wird alles wiederkommen
nur im moment ist es halt noch nicht so
weit auch neubacher zeige ich ein
interview das er zu beginn der krise
gegeben hat ist wirklich eine große
katastrophe wir kommen alle aus dem
winter im winter ist immer weniger los
und wir alle haben darauf gehofft hat es
ab märz wieder losgeht und wir in die
saison starten es gibt jetzt wieder
lockerungen wir dürfen wieder fahren
aber wir haben eine höchst anstrengende
saison vor uns die barkassen sind 18
meter lang selbst wenn touristen kommen
wie soll er abstände einhalten er habe
so ein maßstab anderthalb meter
tatsächlich an bord wo wir dann messen
wo den nächsten gäste sich hinsetzen
dürfen weil die ja nicht weiß kommt
jemand einzelnen familie zu zweit und so
weiter sein humor hat neubacher trotz
allem nicht verloren
nach dieser krise bezahlen da noch
schlimme ist jetzt kommen im nächsten
jahren ganz ehrlich spielen mag es nicht
mehr
hoffen wir dass er recht hat und die
nahe zukunft wieder mehr touristen eine
bootstour buchen
auch am nächsten morgen ist der
hamburger hafen fast menschenleer
normalerweise arbeiten hier mehr als 150
tausend leute wahrscheinlich gibt es
niemanden hier der nicht von der krise
betroffen ist dem fisch großhandel von
kali hosen sprachen von einem tag auf
den anderen alle aufträge weg er musste
seine langjährigen mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit schicken
wir machen ja auch privat viel mitnehmen
wenn man dann quasi seinen freunden
sagen muss dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten
können und jetzt nur noch 60 prozent von
ihnen netto bekommen um diese ganzen
geschichten
das ist nicht schön also dass das wieder
gänsehaut das macht wirklich keinen spaß
man will den jungs dann ja auch
irgendwie helfen aber eigentlich kaum
möglichkeiten
mittlerweile macht nie wieder etwa 30
prozent seines normalen umsatzes und er
glaubt fest daran dass ein unternehmen
es schaffen wird so lieber optimistische
äußerungen wie die ganze zeit irgendwie
negativ zu denken
wir müssen jetzt sehen dass es
weitergeht das was kommt das kommt
darüber freuen wir uns und was nicht da
ist das ist nicht da nicht beeindruckt
dieser ruhiger hanseatischer optimismus
egal welche branche
egal welcher wirtschaftszweig die korona
krise trifft jeden auch hier in
wildeshausen bei oldenburg hat sie
natürlich nicht halt gemacht
herzlich willkommen in unserer kleinen
draußen runde
heike demter ist physiotherapeutin seit
das wetter es zulässt bietet sie ihren
patienten das sportprogramm im garten an
hat es jetzt hier so selbstverständlich
aussieht war noch vor wenigen wochen
undenkbar
dem ta hatte umsatzeinbußen von mehr als
70% wir wissen nicht wie es weitergeht
wir haben richtig massive existenzängste
und es grassiert im grunde genommen die
angst ums nackte überleben
wie fühlt sich das an wenn sie das sehen
also das war auch so in dem moment wo
wir wirklich gedacht haben wir schaffen
es nicht also wenn das halbe geschäft
dem gruppen sport weg ist dann sind die
kosten immer noch da aber es kommt nur
noch die hälfte rein und da bleibt
einfach nix über so einfach ist das herr
gedimmt da musste ihre sekretärin
entlassen und die mitarbeiterinnen ging
in kurzarbeit jetzt aber geht es wieder
bergauf
also heute guckt mal wieder mehr nach
vorne zu machen total spaß dass die
gruppen wieder starten die leute freuen
sich alle
man hat sich so durch die zeit gekämpft
und fängt jetzt an sich wieder zu
entspannen so langsam entspannen tun
sich auch mehr und mehr die patienten
sie kehren zurück in die praxis und
nehmen einzelbehandlungen war für die
therapeuten eine herausforderung
haben sie angst denn der direkte
körperkontakt ist ja hier nicht zu
vermeiden
angst nicht respekt schon also man
verdrängt es ein bisschen weil ansonsten
könnte ich glaube ich gar nicht arbeiten
wenn ich da ich bei jedem patienten
darüber nachdenken würde nicht so viel
nachdenken einfach weitermachen
mittlerweile findet etwa die hälfte
aller therapien wieder statt
unsere fahrt durch corona land geht
weiter in richtung südwesten in dortmund
regnet aber mir ist das egal
ich gehe heute abend ins kino popcorn
das autokino vor dem alten hochofen gibt
es erst seit wenigen wochen
wir haben alle an einem strang gezogen
haben wir das einfach etwas auf die
beine gestellt wusste selber nicht so
worauf wir uns einlassen aber man wächst
ja auch in seinen aufgaben ja und jetzt
sind wir hier und machen jeden abend
neuen film versuchen die leute irgendwie
ein bisschen von ihrem corona alltag
abzulenken
[Musik]
bei mir klappt das hervorragend ich bin
zum ersten mal im autokino und muss
sagen zumindest für den rest des abends
ist mir corona ziemlich egal
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen führt meine reise
weiter nach köln es ist kalt und
regnerisch
mich nervt das wetter der rhein ist grau
in grau und der dom hat auch schon mal
besser ausgesehen
in dieser kirche hier in köln-mülheim
finden seit wenigen tagen wieder
gottesdienste statt
aber die gläubigen und erfahren müssen
eine ganze reihe von auflagen war
wer den gottesdienst besuchen möchte der
darf ohne mundschutz und das eintragen
in die besucherliste die kirche nicht
betreten
die oberen ränge bleiben frei und unten
sind die stühle mit großem abstand
zueinander aufgestellt
es hat nicht gesungen werden von der
gemeinde weil daher die aero sohle
besonders weit fliegen und insgesamt
gibt es eben durch den abstand dann auch
eine höchst personal hier in der kirche
das sind ungefähr 25 wenn jetzt eine
familie zu dritt kommt dann können wir
noch einen daneben setzen aber insgesamt
ist das eben das was wir machen können
für die musikalische untermalung hat
pfarrer berliner nun eine sängerin
engagiert
[Musik]
so kommt zumindest etwas stimmung
während dieser doch eher ungewöhnlichen
zusammenkunft auf wissen wir alle dass
es eigentlich schöner wäre wenn es
anders wäre aber wir sehen auch die
notwendigkeit und was wir eigentlich
nicht begegnet es um verständnis für die
maßnahmen oder für die situation fahrer
und kirchenbesucher sind froh endlich
wieder in direktem kontakt sein zu
können
also das ist natürlich schon komisch
wenn man so vereinzelt dann da irgendwie
sitzt aber es besser als nix was bringt
ein stück normalität wieder zurück weil
die zeit ist ja komisch und ja und freut
sich über jedes etwas was einem wieder
irgendwie ein bisschen normalität geben
über ein stück mehr normalität freut
sich auch luise ich bin mit ihr
verabredet die 35-jährige zahnärztin hat
krebs
mit beginn der korona krise hatte sie
sich in selbst quarantäne begeben groß
war damals die angst sich mit corona
anzustecken
also ich bin in der super schwierigen
situation dass ich einfach wirklich
nicht raus gehe ich habe zu große angst
ich bekomme ja eine therapie zur zeit
und das ist halt nicht so richtig klar
wie schlimm es bei mir werden könnte
eigentlich hatte luise nach jahrelanger
therapie endlich wieder licht am ende
des tunnels gesehen dann kam corona acht
lange wochen blieb die risikopatientin
mit ihren drei kleinen kindern allein zu
hause
das war schon sehr schlimm für mich
nicht weil ich wollte einfach jetzt
irgendwie wieder mein leben zurück ich
wollte wieder mal weg ich wollte meine
freunde treffen ich wollte mit den
kindern ein schönes machen
die letzten zwei jahre habe ich
eigentlich nur im krankenhaus verbracht
nur welche therapien besprochen nur
geguckt hat sich wieder auf die beine
komme und jetzt sind jetzt auch noch der
hat auch noch das
die wochenlange betreuung der kinder
kostete viel kraft luises man selbst
arzt und systemrelevant konnte nur am
abend unterstützen als die fallzahlen
sanken meldete luise ihre kinder in der
not betreuung an
und seitdem ist es dann schritt für
schritt irgendwie bergauf gegangen für
uns alle und das fühlt sich jetzt
richtig an und die angst vor einer
ansteckung ist eigentlich im moment im
hintergrund eher weil die zahlen so
niedrig sind und weil ich mich ja auch
ansonsten alles halte also ich gehe
nicht in restaurants gewusst ich treffe
nicht 1000 leute das heißt die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist einfach auch
nicht so hoch hoffe ich für menschen wie
luise müssen wir auch in zukunft
voneinander abstand halten das wird mir
bei diesem besuch noch einmal ganz klar
und auch dass ich aufhören sollte mich
über das wetter zu ärgern
die letzte station meiner reise ist
geldern im kreis kleve zu beginn der
krise habe ich den hortensien
produzenten andreas pellens interviewt
damals war er verzweifelt viele aufträge
weggebrochen
die märkte stornieren trotzdem weil die
angst haben dass sie die ware nicht
verkauft kriegen somit bleiben wir
natürlich auf wahnsinnigen summen sitzen
mich hat dieses interview damals sehr
bewegt also für uns ist es wirklich
existenzbedrohend
was für eine scheiße ich finde ich
wirklich schlimm
und jetzt will ich natürlich wissen wie
es ihm heute geht auf 15 hektar fläche
produziert pellens hortensien die angst
um seinen traditionsbetrieb war groß wie
gehts super
ja das ist wirklich es hat sich um 180
grad gedreht seit unserer letzten
begegnungen die abverkäufe sind da die
absätze sind da die leute freuen sich
über blumen
das macht uns glücklich nach der
ausstrahlung des berichts im
morgenmagazin erhielt pellens riesigen
zuspruch von zuschauern
sie alle wollten helfen um die kurz vor
der blüte stehenden hortensien zu retten
auf meinem smartphone 90 nachrichten von
personen quer das bundesgebiet verteilt
wo kann man ihre pflanzen kaufen wir
wollen pflanzen haben und ja dann habe
ich zu meiner frau gesagt egal jetzt
starten wir den ab hof verkauf und das
ist ein wahnsinnserfolg einen teil
seiner verluste konnte pellens durch den
hofladen auffangen und er läuft bis
heute die hortensien sind ausgepreist
und das geld werfen die kunden einfach
in diesen briefkasten vertrauens kasse
genau
manchmal ist kess geld genau ihre oder
und auch völlig logisch dass sich dieses
prachtstück hier am ende meiner reise
mit nach hause nehmen
[Musik]